alright so there's a new things that you
can find on the boards inside the safe
houses so you you you need first of all
to clear a named own of all the end
contours and side mission and then if
you go to the safe house you can
interact with the ball you don't have to
clear the Intel right now sorry okay all
right no just the end content on the
site night so search are destroyed
random events that spawn in different
name zone where you get to kill find and
kill a groups of NPC so they are n
contours and each time you clear one of
those income tell you will get one token
so now we can see gave who is actually
entering the dark zone so ya know he's
going if it wasn't a danger of dying
before now he know there's a bit more is
because yes what kind of enemies should
we explode there we are 221 and plus
gearscore so he just started in the
north of it and in the north you will
face level 34 NPCs so yeah really tough
you will have to be really coordinated
with your team and be extra careful but
at the same time the reward from those
NPCs is the best reward you can have in
the game guaranteed to 100 for second
thoughts on second thought I spaying so
do you want take in this you will not
see anything else than orange division
tech in that bracket so only high-end
only I end yeah not orange I and so
every time you saw a green a blue
division technique for that will now be
the high end yeah okay so already you
can see the signs of graffiti and all
sorts of things in a clear signs of the
Rikers and also we will notice that so
gearscore 160 actually so this the
requirements no it's the recommended
guess call the ring I guess that's the
off mode so it's the same as a different
file conversed so yeah contrary to what
people may have something there
not again for nice now it's not to marry
Quentin sexual oh also a good night
that's a that's the records shooting
down we did say they're shooting down
the yeah there you go so that looks like
we were headed well I'm glad we got my
time like you said this is this is cool
and you was actually saying earlier that
if you see the guys hanging right is
this these are basically two point O
hanging feet guys to point total corpses
so they will depending on the the
current weather in the currently they
will sway more or less ok so the windy
of this y-yeah the windier this we're
all right that's totally a word so about
the measure hmm nice you actually need
to be much more mobile mobile in this
incursion compared to Falcon and I was
like yeah yeah obviously there are
multiple strategies with Falcon last
people find themselves down pit with
generators or down to the left side
there but this is a entirely different
ball game can you take us through what
this this first pack is in in your world
so this this very first feed worse it's
a bit of a like a gear check for the
players if they if you have a hard time
getting through this you're gonna well
let's just say that it won't have a
particularly good time when you get to
the final final combat encounter and to
just to make make people happy there are
checkpoints ok so the checkpoint after
this yes there is the check on that all
right ok so it's not like I gonna have
my rights all the work don't have to do
it nice it's obviously since this is as
we said the difficulties sending out
Falcon loss so when you're actually
playing it with the team that has been
already playing program respective a tin
house with tesco
this is the hard mode so it's it's
really it's doable welder yeah well
until the way I think there's a gear
perspective it's doable but the strategy
that you have to employ inside the
circle is not going to be probably
apparent for people as soon as they jump
in specifically like clear sky you
really need to get get your different
roles in order I mean you need a
dedicated tank you need people focusing
on like different areas and different
targets because if you leave that leave
the wrong mob alive are you gonna have a
terrible time you can do it don't die
now ok I want to show people the inside
of the circle right so now it's open
that one thing that I think is it's
extremely cool about this is that the
art our team spent a lot of time like
almost replicating this area yes you if
you know the area realize you're gonna
go right at home sort of actually
because I remember after people got the
first taste of bryant park especially
New York native study they were saying
to us I thought it was really cool like
to see Bryant Park because I go through
if bryant park every day went on my way
to work or something so anyone who lives
in New York or around that area and we
would love to hear from you on what you
think of this incursion of Columbus
Circle
you